okay so i just remembered a story from
high school that i literally have to
tell you guys so i was on the volleyball
team in high school and before each
season we would have a team sleepover
and for whatever reason on the sleepover
we thought it would be so funny to tp
our own quarterback and it wasn't
because we had beef with him or anything
like he was fine we just thought it
would be funny so we went there and
literally absolutely destroyed his house
like there was over a hundred rolls of
toilet paper found and we thought it
would be even funnier if we pinned it on
our rival school so we rode on the
driveway at 10 days cls which was the
acronym of the opposing high school and
the football team played them in 10 days
so it was pretty clear who we were
putting it on and we thought it would be
funny and we could just probably tell
them in a couple days like it would just
be a funny joke but it became the
biggest deal like coaches from the other
school were getting involved coaches
from our school were getting involved
administration was getting involved
trying to figure out who did it i'm
running out of time so like for part two